[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه 60 برنامج
البدايه من العناوين
جديده
2015 كلمه سر في الهجوم البريه التركيه
المحتمل على شمال سوريا
ملف المغيبين والمختطفين في العراق خفيه
لكره القدم مع وجه المشرق تقليله نسب
الجريمه والقمه الفقر قد تكون نعمه
[موسيقى]
اليقطموا على المكارم والمهالك عند
الضروره وثبات الجيش عند المخاوف هذا هو
وصف الشجاعه والايرانيون شجعان والوصف
للرئيس الامريكي بعيدا وايضا ان نظيره
الفرنسي
هؤلاء هم الغرب هو رئيس ايران اي يكرروا
دعوته الى ما يصفه باحباط مخططات الاعداء
هذه المخططات يبدو انها تاتي من النظام
بنفسه افعلوا اي شيئا لجعل المواطنين
يعتقدون ان الاحتجاجات من عمل الاجانب
حديث المرشد بحسن تسريبات نشرتها ايران
انترناشونالنها بعد قليل شجاعه الايرانيين
تتوازن مع ارتفاع عدد القتلى قتله
الاحتجاجات 468
صبي منظمه حرانه الحقوقيه الضغط يتزايد
وفي المقابل تجديد وسائل القمع عما تضروره
الاعتقالات بالطبع جزء منها حتى في صفوف
النظام محمد باقر باختيار القائد السابق
بالحرس الثوري اعتقله الامن وهو من فجر
قصه محسن اميني اصلا باختيار المطلع على
التفاصيل بحكم منصبه السابق ووصف النظام
بانه هي وغير مسؤول الاختطاف وقتل
المسؤولين الحكوميين والنشطاء والصفيين في
جميع انحاء العالم وسيله اخرى 15 مسؤولا
في واشنطن واوروبا والشرق
الاوسطن بوست هذا الى جانب اداه اخرى
متشدده هاجم امير حسين موسى
خاتمي وايضا روحاني واتهمتهم بحراسه
المصالح الامريكيه في ايران
مولويه عبد الحميد ايضا امام السنه في
بلوشستان الذي طالب السلطات بوقف القمه لم
يسلم الطبخ
[موسيقى]
والدليل ما شاهدناه قبل قليل تجمعات
للتضامن امام مول عبد الحميد الشباب وقود
الانتفاضه لم يعد يصدق روايات النظام
وباتوا يشددون الخناقه اكثر فاكثر دعواتنا
لاضراب عام من الخامس وحتى السابع من ادي
ديسمبر الجاري وفي مقابل ذلك النظام لا
يصمت هذا قديم يجددها القتل والصاق التهما
بالانتحار المتزايد اصلا في ايران بسبب
الوضع المترديه هذا مراهقه عرش يا امام
ساده 16 عاما انتحر بعد يومين فقط من
اطلاق سراحه اعتقل الان لمده ايام بتهمه
اسقاط العمامه
لكن حال انتحر امنتحر والدته ذهبت الى
الاحتمال الثاني ماذا فعل بك عدو عدو
الشرف هؤلاء انت لم تكن اللي تنتحر هذه
الاحاديث جعلت التهديدات تظهر وقوات الامن
اقتحمت منزل الاسره وحددت افرادها اذا
تكلمتم سينالكم السوء انشطه الاهوازيه
عاطفه انعامي ايضا مثال اخر عثر عليها
مقتوله في شقتها وشقيقها ومنها فده ان انت
حاره شقيقته سيناريو ملافق ولا يمنع ذلك
ايضا السلطات من القتل المباشر في اكثر
مثال شرشا نيك نام 30 وعدت زوجته الثار لن
اكون امراه ان لم تنتقل لك
فارس
المحتاجين ولا الشهر الثالث تحت مطلبي
اسقاط النظام واكثر ما يهدد باطفائها هو
اختلاف المعارضين لما ستكون عليه البلاد
بعد السقوط على هذا الوتر بدات مرحله
التكتيك الجديده اصوات من اجهزه الامن
وكبار الساسه قعدوا التقييم وهؤلاء يعلمون
جيدا ان الشارع ليس بيدهم وانهم لن يكونوا
بمؤمن في حال تداع النظام لذا يحاولون
استماره العمى المتشدده لفكرتين الاولى
الا حل دون اصلاح بنيه النظام والثانيه ان
الفجوه ستتعمق اذا تم تبني خطوات تجميليه
لعمليه المعالجه وهو ملفات اليه رئيس مجلس
الشورى محمد
فكره متاخره والوصفه اللي صحيفه مستقل
وبين هاتين الفكرتين ثالثه
تعيني ابراهيم رئيسي على راس القضاء لكن
هل هي فعلا خطوه حقيقيه لمحاربه الفساد
كما يروج لها الاصلاحين ام انها جرعه املا
بعمر الافتراضيه قصيرا جدا تفسير لا يزال
غير واضح لكن اكيد ان الوصول الى نقطه
النهايه في الاحتجاجات هو عين الاجتهاد
المطلوب الان وهناك من توصل لضروره خلق
نوخبا سياسيه من اطياف جديده بما يضمن
تشتيت اصوات النزعه الانفصاليه خصوصا في
المناطق الكرديه
فوجهاء محافظه كردستان تجرؤوا على طلب
استفتاء على مشروعيه النظام واهله
بلوشستان مستمرون بالمطالبه بحقوقهم رغم
استشراس الامن والاضطرابات في كراج تنتقل
الى طيران وتخترق الحواجز العرقيه
ريفراندومي
ومع حضور معتمدان وراهبران الديني وملي
واهمش لنزارتنا هاد هاي بين الملاليه
بتراف جهتي بنور رافت كونونياستين
في الحوزه العلميه والصديقان خامنئي ورئيس
ايران الاسبق رفصا جاني حتى في سنوات سجن
خامنئي عاشت عائلته في منزل عائله صديقه
هذه العائله وامام التهديدات الحاليه
يحاول خامن اللجوء اليها لكن الصديقان
اصلا
بينهما الخلافات اعترف بها خامن اي وقت
وفاه رخصا جاني ويبدو ان ما فعله خامنئي
لا يزال حاضرا اذاكره عائله نفساني ام
هندس صعود الاول لمنصب المرشد لكن
حلمه ببناء دوله منفتحه تحطم عام 2013 لم
يسمح له بالترشح للرئاسه اليوم خامنئي
يحتاج لمن يعينه على اخماد حرك عصيا على
التوقف ويهدد به ايطاحه عرشنا
منذ ثلاثه واربعين عاما وهنا تظهر عائله
الصديق لكنها
الثامنه احترقت في الميدان وفي الكواليس
ايضا اذ فشل المرشد باقناعي زعماء
المعتدلين من عائله رفس جاني والقضيمي
وحتى خاتمي
بركه احتراق الصوره ايضا من طرف اخر وبيد
الاشقاء ابنه الشقيقته لا تريد التعامل مع
نظام دموي
»
الاصلاحين والمعتدلين من الساحه السياسيه
مستغلا سلطته النافذه على مجلس صيانه
الدستور صفوه تجلت في انتخابات 2021 فوزي
رئيسي عكس توجهاته المتشدده الضيق
المنافسه بين المترشحين واخرج شخصيه يثق
بها الشعب من المعادلات السياسيه يدفع
نظام وتحديدا المرشده خطيئه بدات عام 89
حينما قال انا لا استحق هذا المنصب كان
ذلك قبل الاحتجاجات اما الان منصبه الذي
ظن انه للابد مهدد
تخوف المرشده الايراني وخلقه اللم ياتي من
فراغ اظهرته وثقام مسربه والوثائق المسربه
تتوالى وتماما كما فعلت الاحتجاجات براس
النظام بنفسه الاختراقات الالكترونيه تظهر
مدى هشاشه النظام السيبراني في ايران
هاكرز بلاك ريبورد الذين سبق لهم اختراق
هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه الان
اخترقوا وكاله انباء فارس وتحديدا نشره
سريه مكونه من 123 الصفحه والتسريبات
دائما تكمل روايه السلطات غير الكامله هل
نعلم ما هو عدد المتظاهرين في الشارع في
العالم اقل من 40,000 شخص اما في الخفاء
قائد الحارس الثوري حسين سلام يقدر العدد
بي 60
البسيج قوات خمنائيه التي تحفظ له السلطه
في على النجاح اما في الخفاء فشلت ابي كسر
باس المحتاجين بل وسنظفت وهنا الحديث اللي
خامنئي المرشد غاضب ومتوتر تكتيكم
الدراجات الناريه للبسيج باقتحان مناطق
الاحتجاجات وتنفيذ الاعتقالات نجح في 2009
لكن تبدو الصوره مغايره الان رقعه
الاحتجاجات تتوسع في اكثر من 120 مدينه
سوره البسيج مهتزه في اعين خامنئي
النظام نعم كما ذكرنا قبل قليل للصديق
والشقيق الابواب مو صداقه عذاب واحد الكرم
اثر مسيرات الايرانيه بدا واضحا في
اوكرانيا فرد الدين واجب المخابرات
الروسيه زودت السلطات ابي نتائج تنصت
اجهزه غربيه على ايران لكننا نتائج التنصت
ليست جيده الايرانيون في حاله ثوره النظ
في فوضى الحكومه مرتبكه والمواطنون لم
يعودوا يخشون القوات العسكريه والشرطه
هكذا تشير تسريبات
[موسيقى]
العمران
الله
[موسيقى]
والصلاه على النبي
ان شاء الله
الباحثه في شان الايراني اهلا بك اذا في
الخفاء ولكن هناك تسريبات بدات تفضح هذا
المشهد السري في ايران البسيج فشل وذلك
بحسب خامنئي بنفسه هذه هي التسريبات التي
تتحدث انها خامنئي يقر بفشل واستنزاف
البسيج وحين يفشل البث ما هي خيارات
النظام المقبله
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين يعني بالفعل هذا
الوثيقه المطوله التي تم يعني تم تسريبها
بطريقه اخرى تبين مدى عجز النظام في
مواجهه الاحتجاجات وبالفعل خامني امم حسب
كتب في تقرير منزعج لماذا لم يستخدم ادوات
اكثر ممكن عنفا انه ااه او اكثر جديه لقمع
الاحتجاجات همم لذلك يعني
اكثر من القتل والاعتقالات والساق التهم
التشويه تشويه السمعه ماذا يمكن ان يفعل
اكثر من ذلك حتى استخدام المسيرات
الاخيره اللي كانوا دائما يتخوفون شعب
الايراني فيها سيناريو السوريه لانه دائما
كان يقولون في حال قمت في
سوره ما او احتجاجا ما سيكون مصيركم مصير
سوريا اكثر من مره عندما كان هناك
احتجاجات بسبب تدخلنا في سوريا كان يقولون
في حاله نحارب بسوريا لازم نحارب ده داعش
في داخل حدود الايرانيه يعني لا استطيع ان
يبداون في خلق سيناريوهات جديده بوجود
منظمات ارهابيه بين القوسين مثل داعش همم
ولكن في النهايه هم يكونوا خلفها فيضعون
الشعب امام اما الامان همم اما الحياه
يعني فلذلك يعني
هاي احد السنه
ايران الى حرب اهليه
الى التسريبات والتاكيد على ضروره ترسيخ
الاتهامات الاتهامات
بالاجنده الخارجيه او التدخل الخارجي الان
المتهمون يعني من بينهم روحاني ايضا
القائد السابق في الحرس الثوري من يصدق
هذه الاتهامات
بالنسبه لهم لا يهمهم نصدق او لا نصدق
لانه يحتاجون يلومون جهه الماء وهل هناك
احتفالات داخليه داخل الانظمه النظام نحن
لا نز- الاخ حسن روحاني الان في السجن همم
بسبب اتهامه ايضا بالعلاقه مع الدول
الاجنبيه على رقم انه اخ حسن روحاني كان
في مفاوضات الملف النووي همم حسن روحاني
من مدينه سمنان ولديهم لغه
ما يعرفوها الكثيرون لذلك عندما كانوا
يتواصلون بين طهران حتى يقدمون لهم
التطورات ملف النووي الاخين كانوا يتكلمون
بلغه احد المناطق في سنان حتى الاروفين لا
يعرفون ما يحصل من تبادل الحديث بين ال
همم بين الحكومه الايرانيه اللي موجود في
دول الغربيه ولكن حتى هذا لم يشفع لهم
وقتهامه حسن روحاني انه عمي ولكن لا يهمهم
في النهايه لانهم ممكن يريدون ان يستغلون
هذه اللحظه ايضا لانه ممكن لديهم امل ان
يستطيعون هون الموقف ويتخلصون من اشخاص
ممكن يكونون منافسين في المستقبل لا ننسى
انه حرس الاشخاص لا يزالون يمتلكون رصيد
في الشارع الايراني اشكرك جزيل الشكر معنا
من بروكسل عبر سكايب منسله والباحثه في
الشان الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
شماله وسوريا السبب هل يعود التوتر بين
واشنطن وانقره في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الشمال السوريين مشتعل
اذا انا ولا جهه الفاعلات كثيره الطرف
الاول اساسي طبعا تركيا تقصف مواقع
التابعه للمسلحين الاكراد وتهددو باجتياح
البري الطرف الثاني روسيا ارسلت تعزيزات
العسكريه لمناطق تسيطر عليها القوات
الكرديه وقوات النظام السوري في حلب اما
لوقف او تاخير العمليه التركيه بحسب
المرصد السوري
بقيادته واشنطن يستانف اليوم دوريته
المعتاده في مناطق سيطره الاكراد بعد ما
تم تقليصها من قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه او
ما يعرف بقصد طرف رابع خاصه التي اوقفت
اليوم ايضا جميع عمليات مكافحه الارهاب
المشتركه مع التحالف وطلبت من روسيا
التدخل لدى انقره وهنا يظهر توتر اعتدنا
رؤيته بين انقره
الاخيره طلبت الاولى باعاده تقييم خطوط
العمليات البريات
ردت انقره لحفه واشنطن على الوفاء
بالالتزامات ما هي بحسب وزير الدفاع
التركي الكف عن تصليح مجموعات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
منوره جديده ام مواجهه للتهديد ورقه
داخليه
ايا كان يبدو الرئيس التركي عاقدا عزمه
على شان قوه بلاده هجوما بريا من الحدود
الجنوبيه نحو شمال سوريا وتحديدا 30 كم
للدقه لكن المكاس تتجاوز الامان والامن
القومي وفي التاريخ ليس البعيد نحن فيه
2015 العمليه الاولى التركيه
والتنميه يخسروا اغلبيته البرلمانيه في
انتخابات السابع من يونيو بعد اشهر في
نوفمبر 2015 تحديدا وعقب سلسله تفجيرات في
البلاد اعيد الانتخابات وهذه المره فاز
حزب العداله والتنميه بزياده قدرها خمسه
ملايين صوت الان
2022 تتوفر الظروف ذاتها والحاجه اكبر في
بلدنا يعيش اعمى ازمه اقتصاديه في تاريخه
الانتخابات وعلى الابواب ومصير حزب
العداله والتنميه على المحاكم وعمليه على
اكراد سوريا من شانها ان تسقطبها اصوات
القوميين مع رهان على احداث شرخ وانقساما
في صفوف المعارضه حولها سناخذ الورقه
الداخليه ونعبر بها الحدود الى الجهه
الاخرى في الشمال السوري وهنا يقف الخصم
بحسب تركيا ضربات الجويه التركيه تمطر
مقارا المقاتلين الاكراد متحفزون وربما
منهكون بتعزيزتنا تترقبوا منذ اشهر
العمليه التركيه والرهان هنا معلقا على
الحمايه الامريكيه كما كان الحال في
العمليات التركيه السابقه
خابت التوقعات هذه المره واشنطن تتفهم
المخاوف التركيه بحسب مسئوليها وقصد هو
سوريا الديمقراطيه تمنت رساله امريكيه
اقوال لمنع الاشتياح لكن في الاحجيه قطعه
اخرى روسيا في المشهد ونشطه ايضا سواء في
الوساطه ام لاستثمار مصلحه فهي فاعله بقدر
واشنطن وذلك لموقعها على خريطه نفوذها
الراسخه في سوريا وبين التوازنات
والتفاهمات التركيه الامريكيه من جهه
والتركيه الروسيه من جهه اخرى تلعب انقره
على الموازنه بين تنسيقها مع الفاعلين
وبين اتخاذها القرار فماذا تقول
بسم الله
[موسيقى]
الروسيه الامريكيه لها وبالتالي تركيا
اسطنبول الاخيره مثلا دفعه للتحرك التركي
جوا والاشتياح البري له حساباتنا مختلفه
تتعلق بنجاعه الهجوم كوارث
السلام الاسم الذي اطلقته تركيا على
عمليتها العسكريه الثالثه في شرق الفرات
في 2019 وبعد فرضها واقع على الارض
اتفهمات مع موسكو واشنطن اوقفت العمليه
اليوم تعلن انقره المخلب السيف في اتجاه
وتعول في اخر على الوساطه الروسيه لتلبيه
المقاتلين الاكراد لما طالبها دون قتال
وبنسحابهم منبج عين العرب وتل رفعت بل
وتسليم مقار قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه لقوات
النظام
وهنا واقع اخر جديد تحاول تركيا ترسيخه
منذ مده تتفق فيه مع روسيا ان لم تكن
موسكو هي من تدفع باتجاهه وبقوه وسنعود
اليه بكل الاحوال في الوساطه الجمعه قائد
القوات الروسيه في سوريا
بقائد قصد مظلوم عبدي في مدينه القامشلي
لترحيل الرساله التركيه الاخيره قبل بدء
العمليات البريه
في شمال وشرق سوريا كذلك الذي فرضته في
2018 في الجنوب سلسله اتفاقيات تكون فيها
الضامن فيما يستفيد النظام السوري بالدخول
الى مناطق اوسع تماما كما ساعد في نوفمبر
العام الماضي الى ادخال ثلاثه الاف مقاتل
من قوه النظام الى عين العرب لكن هل هي
مصلحه خالصه لنظام
الاجابه في الشروط والمحددات التي تحكم
الساحه السوريه موسكو لها مطالبه في شمال
غرب البلاد وبالتالي لا يمكن القبول باي
تدخل تركي الا في حال تلبيتها على الاقل
في طريق الام فور الخط الدولي الذي يمر
بمنبج ليربط بين شرق سوريا وغربيها روسيا
تريد ضمان ضروره فتحتها وان يكون امنا
ايضا مبادله اخرى جبل الزاويه جنوبي ادلب
حيث تتمركز القوات التركيه في 16 قاعده من
سحاب الاكراد من المناطق الثلاث وربما
يكون ذلك سيناريو افضل حتى بالنسبه
للاكراد فالغارات الجويه لم تعد تقتصر على
الاهداف ضمن عمق 30 كلم بل تجاوزتها لتجمل
ايضا ما هو غير عسكري دير الزور البعيده
عن الحدود باكثر من 70 كيلو مترا قصفها
الطيران التركي ولي اول مره وهنا اهداف
اخرى ايضا اقتصاديا نشات تكرير النفط
تشغلها قصد في منطقه ارملان الغنيه بالنفط
والتي توجد بالقرب منها قوات امريكيه ورغم
ذلك لا خوف امريكي على مصالحها حقلا عمر
وورد خارج المعادله وهما ما يدور اهتمام
واشنطن حولهما اذا هي تداخلات معقده للقوه
في المناطق التي يضع صانع القرار التركيه
عينه عليها والنفوذ تجعل من التعقيد
مضاعفا ما يتطلب استغلال الطاقهات
والتوظيف التناقدات حتى وان لم تكن انقره
بحاجه لضوء اخضر
[موسيقى]
لكن على ماذا تعول تركيا اليوم اولا على
طبيعه العلاقه مع النظام السوري يبدو ان
هناك تغيير خلال اسبوع واحد وجه اردوغان
الرسائل ايجابيه وهنا تظهر روسيا محاوله
احداث التقارب مبعوثا الخاص الى سوريا
يتحدث لكن في المقابل ان تستمع تركيا
لدعوه موسكو بعد عدم القيام بعمل عسكري
بري هو امر ثاني تعول عليه تركيا
لتسويه الصراع في اوكرانيا والحديث ايضا
عن فنلندا والسويد ومساله انضمامهما
للنيتو امر تعرضه روسيا طبعا وكانت تعرضه
تركيا بسبب اتهامات للبلدين بدعم المسلحين
الاكراد لكن انقره قد تغير موقفها اعلنت
نهايه نوفمبر احراز البلدين تقدم نحو
الانضمام الحلف ورغم ذلك صحيفه زمان تقول
ان اردوغان قد يعرق الموافقه للامر حتى
منتص عامل مقبل وسيحاول استخدام الامر في
رفع معدلات شعبيته قبل الانتخابات
الرئاسيه رفض العضويه امر وارد ايضا في
حال التغير الجوهري في المواقف الامريكيه
والاوروبيه ضده
والى المزيد ينضم الينا من انقره المحلل
السياسي بركات قار اهلا بك اذا الاوراق
كثيره بيد اردوغان بيد تركيا ومنها ما
تحدثنا عنه للتو عن النيته والضغط على
الناتو بانضمام السويد وتنلندا لكن الورقه
الداخليه الانتخابات تحديدا وتكرار
سيناريو 2015
هلا تتحضر المعارضه لهذا السيناريو الى
هذه الورقه اردوغان
مساء الخير بدايه لك ولا ضيوف الكرام
طبعا ما جاء في تقريركم بالحقيقه
شيء واسعك ويحتاج الى ساعات للنقاش
امور كثيره ملفات كثيره وهناك لاعبين
اطراف متعددين
الانتخابات وهذه الورقه الداخليه التي قد
يستغلها اردوغان في الانتخابات
نعم نعم هي بالحقيقه هذه التوقيت بالذات
كما تعرفون وجاء بالتقريركم ايضا يعني هذه
المساله ليس جديده هذا التهديدات وهذه
النبره الان للتدخل والاشتياح الى اخره من
قبل خمسه اشهر كانت موجوده
وقمه طهران اوقفت هذه العمل وتحولت الامور
ولا احد كان ينتظر في هذا لكن تدهور الوضع
في الداخل والحقيقه تراجع الاصوات
وعدم اجتياز الازمه الاقتصاديه بالنسبه
للسلطه الان لحزب العداله والتنميه خلت ان
تخلق على الاقل مشكله جديده
وتتجه كل اللي اللي صرف النظر عن هذه
الوضع الداخلي الى الخارج والى الامن همم
كما يقال بانه الامن القومي للامن اخلي
والاخر
وعمليه اسطنبول للاسف يعني شيء طبعا اممم
مزعجه كانت وايه مداني طبعا يعني اتت كانه
بورقه جديده
للاستغلال هذه الامر والقيام بهذه الحمل
الجديده
كانت جويه بدايه لكن لم يكتفي في هذه
الامر
اريد ان ننتقل الى نقطه ايضا اخرى وهي
العامل الجديد الذي يدخل على معادله سوريا
الان التقارب التركي مع النظام الذي تدفع
باتجاه روسيا الان هناك مصادر نقلت عنها
رويترز من قلب النظام تقول ان هناك
تمارسها روسيا على النظام للاجلوس في
مفاوضات وفي قمه مع تركيا
يعني لو تحدثنا اكثر عن ذلك وايضا اريد ان
اعرف مصلحه تركيا يعني هناك ايضا هذه
المصادر تقول ان المصلحه تتعلق ايضا
بالانتخابات في تركيا
صحيح صحيح هذا تتعلق ايضا في الانتخابات
وبالحقيقه اذا كان ااا
بوتين بدو يقدم شيء لا اردوغان دعما هو
سيقدم دعم همم على الاقل همم يمثل المساله
الانتخابات يعني وكل المطلوب الان ليس فقط
الدعم الاقتصادي بقدر ما كان بانه على
الاقل هذه الورقه والتسويه والتطبيع اذا
اجازه التعبير مع دمشق هو اللي يخلي اكبر
دعم وهذه الورقه الان بيد المعارضه
المعارضه كلها في تركيا تطالب بتسويه
الامر بسبب اللاجئين التي وصل اعدادهم
كبير ويعتبرون حمل وعباء على على البلد
كله
يتهمون بانه السبب الاقتصاد والى اخره طيب
اردوغان او نسبه لا يستطيع ان بالحقيقه
ياخذ موقف من اللاجئين وعلى الاقل
بارجاعهم الى بلدهم همم قصرا لذلك الان
المعارضه تضغط على الحزب العداله في هذه
الورقه ضغطا كبيرا وهذه الامر همم طلب من
من روسيا على الاقل شكرا
[موسيقى]
ومن سوريا الى العراق حيث ملفات شائكه
كثيره الملف السياسيه بالطبع الفساد الذي
تحدثنا عنه الاسبوع الماضي ولكن هناك ملف
معقد اخر تطورته الحكومات المفقودين
واحبائهم لا تنام الارقام تشير الى ان
العراق ضمن الدول التي تضم اكبر عدد من
المفقودين
قصرا منذ عام 2016 الى 2020 وصل العدد بين
250 الف مليون شخص
اربعه اشخاص والاسباب هنا مختلفه منها
الطائفيه ومنها السياسيه سنتحدث عنها
لاحقا بالطبع لكن لنناخذ منها مثال
البارز في الناصريه سجاد العراقي اختفى في
سبتمبر 2020 بعد تنظيمه عده تظاهرات
مناهضه
المواليه لايران وفسدها اريد ان اعرف
مصيره حيا او ميتا مها كثيره بجانب والده
سجاد يريدنا لقلبه الناعم يطمئن
تسعه اولاد مفقودين
الناس الطيبين يعني اهل المروه الحكومه
يعني اي جهه يقول له انه ولدنا طيبين
[موسيقى]
مسجونين يقولون ميتين يقولون حتى نقطع
نفسنا
الحمد لله هذه يلا المستعان
هذه الروايات والارقام المفزعه فهي مجرد
وايضا من فيض لكن منظمه لكل منظمه او جهه
حكوميه في العراق رقم معين يختلف عن الاخر
بالطبعه تحمل اثار النفسيه لكن هذه الاثار
انعكاسون لهذه الاثار انعكاس ايضا على
الاحبه خارج القضبان اربعه واربعون في
المئه من ذوي المفقودين
المسجلين يعانون من اثار النفسيه كل ليله
ابكي وحيدا لن اترك ابدا مواصله البحث
وربما هذه الكلمات من احد الاباء تلخص وضع
النفسي وهذا الاب ليس وحده ثم غيره الكثير
والكثير لكن ماذا حركت الحكومات العراقيه
من اجل هذا الملف الطويل والثقيل
ينطبقوا على ملفات الفساد ينطبق على هذا
الملف ايضا جهات واحزاب وفصائل فاعله
متهمه والاقتراب وليس سهلا
بدا الامر منذ 2003 لكن بين عامين 2006 و
2008 توسعت هذه العمليات وسجلت في تلك
الفتره سجل في تلك الفتره عمليات اختفاء
اختطاف غدتها فتنه الطائفيه قالت لها حقت
الجيش المهدي وفيق بدر وقتها قتلنا وقطن
للالاف من سكان بغداد والبصره الانتمائهم
المذهبي فتره اخرى بين عامين 2014
و2/2017 تحرير واراضا عراقيه من تنظيم
داعش مره اخرى لا تخفى من الشيعه الحسد
الشعبي
في كشف اثار بعض الجرائم مقبره جماعيه في
محافظه الصلاه الدين تضم رفه مدنيين قيل
انهم اختفوا منذ 50 سنوات وهذا مختطف سابق
وشقيق ومختطفا سابق لدى داعش سيد احمد
الهاشمي
يروي تفاصيل الالم
انا من الناس اللي انسجن في داعش
ووصلتي لحد القتل بعد اخويا اخذوني بقيت
تقريبا فتره معينه لا استطيع ان اذكرها من
قد ما الالم اللي انا بيها تقريبا يا 15
ايام تقريبا ظليت في سجون داعش في قضاء
البعاج
التحرير الموصل
قطعت الاخبار بالكامل
عن اخونا وما نعرف همم وين راحوا وهؤلاء
الناس
المشايخ والساده والعمده والضباط
المنتسبين كثيرين كانوا في السجون لم نعلم
انهم شيء لحد هذه اللحظه هم مغيبين
بالكبار
هذا الحديث يتماشى معه بياناته من رايتس
واتش اتهام الميليشيات ومن بينها فيلق بدر
ولواء علي الاكبر وعصائب اهل الحق وكتائب
حزب الله وسرايا الخرساني وجند الامام
مرارا تكرارا تحاول الحكومه فتح الملف لكن
ما الجدول مثلا في عام 2016 اكثر من 600
مفقود خلال معارك ضد داعش في استقلاويه في
الانبار شكلت شكلت لجنه لكن ماذا عن
النتيجه لا نتائج وهذا ما ينقلنا للنقطه
التاليه المليشيات ليست وحدها بقفصالتها
الشرطه والجيش العراقي ايضا بناء على
شهادات انه وثقتها المنظمه وهذا طبعا
بجانب الخصومات السياسيه ثمنها باهض حراره
تشرين مثال 75 حاله اختطاف موفقه اطلق
سراحه 22 منهم فقط اما البقيه فما زالوا
مجهولي المصير
صحيح ان الارقام متضاربه ولا احصائيات
دقيقه لهذا الملف لكن الثابت ان عشرات
الالاف لا زالوا مفقودين اذا هذه خريطه
المفقودين في الموصل اختفى اكثر من ثمانيه
الاف شخص منذ عام
2014 في محافظه صلاح الدين هناك اكثر من
15 الف مغيبا في ايضا في الانبار هناك
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف شخص مختفا وفي دياله
اكثر من 2000 غياب لكن السؤال اين هم
في البلاد اي يوجد نحو 20 سجنا باعترافي
وزاره العدل العراقيه تساؤل اخر ان كانت
هذه السجون تابعه للدوله فلماذا لا يمكن
العثور على المفقودين الاتهامات تلاحق
المليشيات نظرا لتورطها في عمليات الخطف
والاخفاء لان هذه الفصائل لديها ايضا
سجونها الخاصه وهنا كما تظهر امامكم منطقه
الزعفرانيه بالقرب المدخل الجنوبي للعاصمه
بغداد فهنا يقع سجن شبل الزيدي قائد كتائب
الامام علي والمطور في قضايا عديده ومن
بينها الخطف والقتل ننتقل الان الى شمال
شرق العاصمه بغداد حيث تقع منطقه صدر
القناه حنا يوجد السجن الحشد حيث كان مقرا
للشرطه الاتحاديه سابقا واليوم هو تابع
للمليشيات المسلحه وفي موقع اخر وتحديدا
في منطقه الجاذريه رصافه بغداد توجد دائره
امن ميليشيا
تضم ايضا مراكز توقيف وهذه الدائره تضم
ايضا مقرات ومقار للحرس الثوري الايراني
الى مثلث برمودا العراقي قلعه الميليشيات
والحرس الثوري في الصخر المنطقه المحرمه
على الدوله تنتشروا السجون سريه تابعه
لهذه القوه
في العراق
تفوقاقي عراقي عفوا تفوقنا الرياضي لكن
ليس كرويا الصين وامريكا في الساعه بعد
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
ثلاثه تقوم ملايين وخمسمائه الف نسمه عدده
سكان اوروغواي ومتوسط ودخل الفجر
بكاس العالم في عام 1930 ورقم صعب في
الكره حتى الان لكن هناك دول اخرى تمتلك
ثروات بشريه واقتصاديه اكبر بكثير لا
تمتلكوا منتخبات الصف الاول بكره القدم
كثيره مثل الولايات المتحده والصين تفوقت
في العاب كثيره لكن لم تحقق ذات النجاح في
الرياضه الاكثر شعبيه
ليس كبيرا ف بالعوده لعام
فقط من الصين لاعب كره القدم بالمقارنه مع
عدد السكان اكثر من مليار و400 مليون نسمه
لكن رغم ذلك بكين كما ان لديها خطه سياسيه
ضخمه لديها هدف كروي التحول لقوه عظمى
بحلول عام 2050 كيف مثلا خطط تتضمن بناء
20 الف مركزي تدريبن الجديد بناء اكبر
اكاديميه كره قدم عالميه في اجوانزو
بتكلفه 285 مليون دولار الصين اذا ما
تعملوا على تطوير البنيه التحتيه لكن ليس
ذلك دائما هو المقياس الفقر قد يكون نعمه
في كره القدم لكن كيف مباريات الشوارع
المزدحمه بالاحياء الفقيره كانت نقطه
انطلاق بعضا من اعظم النجوم اللعبه على
غرار مارادونا وميسي وزيدان ومن اجل
الحروب من العبوديه والدفاع عن النفس امام
الاحتلال البرتغاليه اتقنا البرازيليون
هذا والاصول الافريقيه فنا يعرف باسمي
الكابويره الجنكه احدى تقنيه الكابويره
تعتمد على جعل قد من واحده ثابته على
الارض واحداثي المناوغه بالقدم الاخرى
لخداع الخصم واضل تستخدم لتساهم في تطوير
مهارات الاطفال لكن مؤخرا هل استمرت في
وجهه اللاعب البرازيلي السابق قارفينو
الامر تراجع الكثير من النجوم يتحدثون من
يتحولون من الفقر الى الثراء لكن اولئك
الذين نشاوا في اماكن فقيره يواجهنا اكبر
العقبات والعنف والجريمه خاصه تلك
المنتشره في احياء امريكا الجنوبيه ووسط
امريكا القاره التي تضم ثلثي اخطر مدن
العالم الاكوادور مثال بالطبع الحكومه
خرجت من بعض الاحياء وتركت المدنيين ضد
المسلحين وعصابات المخدرات وهنا يظهر
مهاجم منتخب بها في المونديال فالنسيا وعد
بالتبرع باي اموال يحصل عليها
بمساعده الاطفال على الانتقال من المناطق
الاكثر خطوره قد ينجح لاعب واحد في خفض
معدلات الجريمه كما يحدث في المكسيك
انخفاض معدلات الجريمه في اوقات مشاركه
اللاعب خافيير مع ناديه حينها مانشستر
يونايتد
[موسيقى]
لمده 50 عاما تضم قائمه اليونسكو اماكن
معترفه بهذات قيمه عالميه استثنائيه
لحمايتها
كثير من هذه المواقع تحيط بها التحديات
ونحن جزء منها
انشطتنا من التنميه الى السياحه المفرطه
ولنفهم اكثر
تعالوا معنا الى ايطاليا الى البندقيه
اشهر مواقع التراث العالمي المعرضه للخطر
منذ العام الماضي تحاول اليونسكو عدما
ادراجها الى قائمه التراث المعرض للخطر
والمهدد لكن ذلك يتطلب اجراءات عقدت
لاجلها اجتماعا بالامس لكن اي اجراءات هنا
ستمن 25 مليون سائح سنويا هذا معادله 2019
وماذا بيد المنظمه لان تفعلها امام
الفيضانات الشديده المتزايده التي فقمها
تغير
هناك اجراء مهم وهو حظر السفن السياحيه
الكبيره من عبور القنوات المائيه ومن عبور
البحيره وهو ما تم بالفعل بضغط من جماعات
حمايه البيئه لكن الحظره لم يذهب بعيدا
بما يكفي لمعالجه الازمه فهو يخص السفن
التي يزيد وزنها عن 40 الف طن
محاوله اخرى ستبدا مع بدايه العام المقبل
تحول البندقيه الى اول مدينه في العالم
تفرض رسوم دخول اليها وكل الامل هو سيره
السياحي والزوار او ماذا
اختفاءه البندقيه التي ادرجت عام
1987 على قائمه التراث العالمي لليونسكو
اختفاء اثار عصر النهضه الايطاليه
البندقيه واحده من بين ثلاثه وخمسين موقعا
معرضا للخطر ومهددا
وصلنا مشاهدينا الى نهايه مواضيعنا لليوم
وتتابعون غدا في الحرب الاوكرانيه لعبه
الخنادق ومحولات الكهرباء لمن تبتسم وفي
اسرائيل الاميره
نحو رحله المفخخه داخليا وخارجيا
كرتون
احداث الساعه بصور من الانواع حتى الساعه
المقبله انا حنين السوري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]